i just want to start with
congratulations on the series i've seen
the first few episodes um and watching
the show
it looks like this might be the most
challenging shoot that you've both ever
been a part of in terms of like because
it's not a soundstage show it just looks
beautiful to look at but i know what
that means as actors and the crew and
everything can you sort of talk about
that well
thank you for mentioning the crew by the
way because without the crew
that this would not ever it would not
happen and we're working hard but
they're working a lot
yeah it is for sure
1 000
it is by far the hardest thing that i
have personally ever done in my
life in my career as a professional and
tim would say the same thing and coming
from him you know he's like a tough guy
and done a lot of really crazy things
it's challenging
but it needs to be it's meant to be
because it was it was not a uh walk in
the park
you know um this story that that we're
telling and uh
yeah uh the crew wow thank you you're
the first person that's mentioned that
and without them
they have they really just we have
learned so much from all of them the
wranglers and the and the stunt men and
women and it's just been remarkable um
to experience it it was kind of
shocking when we walked into the hotel
to do to set up for these interviews we
were all kind of taken back like oh wow
civilization civilization
we actually get our nails cleaned and
everything i know i was doing mine in
the room i was like oh my god look at
these hagerty things um yeah it's weird
not seeing dirt beneath your nails yeah
i will say or in your ears and
on your
eyes and face in here
i'm actually cured this is more like a
fun question which i wasn't going to ask
but
i am very white if i'm in the sun all
day i just turn red but uh and i'm just
curious how do you both actually make it
through this shoot without being like a
crazy sunburned every day
we wear a lot of sunscreen a lot of
sunscreen but we've also been in very
cold environment we started out in 106
degree weather and we went down to 12
degrees yes with really high winds so we
got like wind burn and yeah
i don't know i don't i think i've just
we have dirt a ton of dirt on my face
ton of dirt on us
so maybe that protects us from the sun
i'm not really sure but you're right if
you go i if i don't know where you're
from but if you go to texas in the
summer you should probably wear a lot of
sunscreen oh yeah
yeah i know completely what i'm curious
uh taylor is obviously a very gifted
screenwriter very gifted writer
and what what are you most excited for
people to see with taylor's writing in
this series
i think what's special about this
project um when it comes to taylor's how
deeply he cares about it um
it's so personal for him
which is why i think we all feel greatly
honored to be a part of something that
matters so deeply to him um bringing
back the west in a way that is like
wow and
when you think of taylor sheridan you
think westerns and then
you can't believe that he hasn't made a
period western like out of everyone
working in you know hollywood today um
he's the one person you would expect to
have already done that but this is his
first which is
uh pretty remarkable
and uh because he live lived a life
group yeah yeah and he's he's he's drawn
from so many of the great westerns like
lonesome dove for this series and um
there's so many little references i
don't know it's uh
it's pretty special
the um
just the
the time that he spent um i forget which
tribe it was but native american tribe
there was a it was a
a year so i think he spent
he lived on a reservation for some time
and so he he but that's what's special
about taylor as well as he he shares the
indigenous experience and brings that to
light in a way that
is often ignored which is so unfortunate
because they have
such a beautiful cook with so many
beautiful cultures and um
yeah that is so special that is one of
the things that i am so grateful yeah to
him for um for sure and uh and also when
you have someone like taylor say that
this is the best thing he's ever written
um
in his own words uh that's
yeah i mean not to make him sound cocky
i think he was saying that i didn't mean
that yeah but like for him for all of
the work that he has done has done which
is pretty
remarkable work um
for him to feel that way about this is
when you say like if like the piece has
left you like yeah a part of you now is
gone
it's that good that's the script is that
good yeah yeah
i was gonna say on that note i gotta
stop i'm just gonna say congrats i know
it's going to be a big hit thank you for
giving me your time
thank you so much thank you bye
you